.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE!
SO THE FORMER NBA PLAYER WAS IN
ROME RECENTLY WHEN HE LEARNED
FROM THE FBI HE NEEDED TO COME
BACK TO THE U.S. IMMEDIATELY.
HE WAS TOLD THE TURKISH
GOVERNMENT HAD PUT A BOUNTY ON
HIS HEAD.
HE GREW UP IN TURKEY BEFORE
COMING TO THE UNITED STATES AND
CHANGING HIS NAME IN HONOR OF
THIS COUNTRY.
HE'S BEEN CRITICAL OF THE
TURKISH GOVERNMENT.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
SO THE TURKISH GOVERNMENT, YOU
WERE INFORMED BY THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT, HAS PUT A BOUNTY ON
YOUR HEAD?
HALF A MILLION DOLLAR BOUNTY?
WHAT'S THAT MEAN?
A BOUNTY ON YOUR HEAD?
>> SO, LIKE, FIRST OF ALL, THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME, MR. CARLSON.
I WAS IN A BASKETBALL CAMP IN
THE VATICAN ACTUALLY FOR
CHRISTIANS, CATHOLIC, MUSLIM AND
JEWISH KIDS.
I HEARD THE NEWS FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
I GOT IN TOUCH WITH THE FBI
IMMEDIATELY.
THEY SAID COME BACK TO AMERICA
THAT THE MOMENT.
SO I TOOK A FLIGHT THE NEXT DAY
AND SO, YOU KNOW, THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME ACTUALLY TURKISH
GOVERNMENT PUT A BOUNTY ON MY
HEAD AND PUT ME ON THE
MOST-WANTED TERRORIST LIST
BECAUSE I TALKED ABOUT THE HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS AND THE
POLITICAL EVENTS HAPPENING IN
TURKEY.
YOU KNOW, I'M NOT THE ONLY ONE.
THERE ARE SO MANY JOURNALISTS,
ACADEMICS, CELEBRITIES AND
PROFESSORS ON THAT LIST.
WHEN I HAD THE CONVERSATION WITH
MY FRIENDS ON THE GROUND, THEY
SAID THE MAFIA, THE SERIAL
KILLERS ACTUALLY, PROFESSIONAL
HIT MEN AND CARTEL COULD BE
AFTER MY CASE I WAS AND
SPEECHLESS.
I WAS LIKE THIS CANNOT BE
HAPPENING TO AN AMERICAN CITIZEN
ON U.S. SOIL!
>> Tucker: DO YOU FEEL LIKE
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT IS HELPING
TO PROTECT YOU FROM THIS THREAT
FROM A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT?
>> REALLY GOOD QUESTION.
YOU KNOW, SOME OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE CONGRESS ACTUALLY REACTING
TO THIS NEWS AND ASKING BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO SPEAK UP AND
ACTUALLY TAKE SOME ACTIONS, YOU
KNOW?
BECAUSE I REMEMBER FIRST TIME
PRESIDENT BIDEN, BEFORE HE TOOK
TO OFFICE ACTUALLY, THE FIRST
THING HE SAID THAT THE PROBLEM
IN MIDDLE EAST IS.
[INDISCERNIBLE]
AND WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT.
IT'S BEEN ALMOST TWO YEARS AND
HE HAS NOT DONE A THING YET.
WE HAVE TO PRIORITIZE HUMAN
RIGHTS BECAUSE TURKEY PLAYS A
VERY IMPORTANT ROLE.
BECAUSE IT COULD BE THE BRIDGE
OF ISLAM AND WEST.
BUT JUST BECAUSE THERE IS NO
FREEDOM OF SPEECH, YOU KNOW,
THERE ARE SO MANY POLITICAL
PEOPLE AND INNOCENT PEOPLE IN
THE JAIL WAITING FOR HELP.
IT IS NOT POSSIBLE.
SO I'M ASKING, PLEASE, BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, TO TAKE SOME
SOLID ACTIONS AND HELP MY
FRIENDS OVER THERE.
HELP MY FAMILY OVER THERE.
I HAVEN'T SEEN THEM ALMOST 10
YEARS!
>> Tucker: IF THEY'RE OK WITH
CHINESE GENOCIDE, I DOUBT
THEY'LL BE TOO UPSET ABOUT T